quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar
cuáles son los antecedentes de este caso
un gusto de estar con ustedes en
particular los antecedentes son
básicamente la sentencia del 2012 en la
actual la corte internacional de
justicia
fija
un área de limitación entre nicaragua y
colombia la cual en un primer instante
pues fue rechazada por colombia en la
medida en que sentía que afectaba sus
intereses y sus derechos
constitucionales
e internacionalmente la podría afectar
esto dio pie para que la república de
nicaragua interpusiera una nueva demanda
en realidad dos demandas pero la que se
paga el día de hoy es la que tiene que
ver con lo que nicaragua denomina las
presuntas violaciones de derechos
soberanos y espacios marítimos en el mar
caribe y qué consecuencias
implicancias tiene este fallo para las
actividades pesqueras de colombia
pues conforme al derecho internacional y
lo que dice la corte internacional de
justicia particular
el área de pesca no puede ir más allá de
el mar territorial que se establece
alrededor del archipiélago y en
particular de las islas principales a
saber san andrés providencia y santa
catalina que están separadas de las
formaciones marítimas que se encuentran
en el norte como roncador quitasueño y
entre las dos hay un espacio en el cual
transita o se establece la zona
económica exclusiva de nicaragua a
juicio de colombia y de la población
real se estarían vulnerando sus derechos
al limitarlos a combinarse solamente a
esas dos semillas marítimas y separarse
de aquellas formaciones que se
encuentran en la parte norte